Can a psychological thriller work as a musical?
Can a high budget action flick be successfully
broken into two parts? We'll be sure to
find out once these 2024 films hit screens.
If anything should put directors Anthony
and Joe Russo's upcoming sci-fi epic "The
Electric State" on viewers' watchlists, it's
the extraordinary cast. Millie Bobby Brown
and Chris Pratt are slated to play the lead
roles, but it's in the supporting cast where
things get really enticing. The film will
feature an ensemble cast of actors in both
live-action and voice-over roles, including
Ke Huy Quan, Brian Cox, and Jenny Slate.
On top of all that, former "Seinfeld" star Jason
Alexander will also be making a rare major
motion picture appearance in the feature.
"Take me to your leader." Laughs.
Outside of the cast, it will also be interesting
to see how the Russos translate the striking
imagery of Simon Stålenhag's "Electric State"
graphic novel into a film adaptation. The
images from the source material make use of
evocative deep blue hues and feature massive
robots lingering around in everyday environments,
leaving a lot of opportunities for the filmmakers
to produce equally striking cinematography through
which they can tell this unique sci-fi story.
Adrian Molina's days at Pixar date back to
2007 when he worked as an animator on the
end titles of "Ratatouille." Since then,
Molina has moved up in the ranks at Pixar
to provide additional screenplay material for
"The Good Dinosaur" and "Monsters University."
He also served as co-director and
screenwriter on the 2017 smash hit
"Coco." Come 2024, Molina will move up
to solo directing Pixar's upcoming title,
"Elio." Details on the project are minimal, but
according to Pixar's official Twitter account,
the film will be a sci-fi yarn about
a young boy who winds up in the far
reaches of outer space and gets mistaken by
alien lifeforms as the ambassador for Earth.
"Coco" was such an extraordinary and
well-renowned feature that the prospect
of any new production from Molina should be enough
of a reason for Pixar fans to celebrate. It will
also be interesting to see Pixar's next
take on the world of sci-fi storytelling,
a domain the studio has explored sporadically
throughout the years to varying results.
For example, "Wall-E" was a fairly resounding
success when it came out in 2008. However,
their more recent attempt at a sci-fi
story, 2022's "Lightyear," received
mixed reviews at best. With so many promising
elements even this early into its production,
"Elio" has the potential to be another storied
chapter in Molina's prolific career at Pixar.
It's been a while since audiences got
to explore the vast and imaginative
world of Miles Morales depicted in 2018's
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse." However,
not only is a sequel to that movie imminent,
but a pair of follow-ups are also on the docket.
The second sequel set in the "Spider-Verse"
universe will be "Spider-Man: Beyond the
Spider-Verse," which is scheduled to hit theaters
in March 2024. Given how scant few details are
available about the first of these sequels,
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse," it's
no surprise that "Beyond the Spider-Verse" is
shrouded in mystery. Most information about which
characters from the first two films will appear in
the third is still not public knowledge, though it
has been confirmed that Jason Schwartzman's Spot
will serve as the main villain in the 2024 film.
Still, the vibrancy of this world makes the
concept of spending more time in the multiverse
of Spider-people incredibly exciting. Plus,
the title "Beyond the Spider-Verse" suggests
some truly trippy storytelling possibilities
could be in store for audiences. We'll have to
wait and see to find out more about what
this particular movie has up its sleeve,
but if the quality of "Into the
Spider-Verse" is any indication,
audiences should get stoked for what
"Beyond the Spider-Verse" has in store.
"Look, I made a promise. So, I have to keep it."
The world of "A Quiet Place" is poised to expand
significantly with the forthcoming spin-off,
"A Quiet Place: Day One." While details about
this film's plot are still largely under wraps,
it does appear that new characters beyond the
original "Quiet Place" protagonists will be taking
center stage, with Lupita Nyong'o and Joseph Quinn
lined up to play two of the new film's leads.
There's also change afoot behind the scenes,
with "Pig" writer and director Michael
Sarnoski taking over John Krasinski's place
as director. With such vast shifts in casting
and leadership, this next installment to the
"Quiet Place" universe could offer something
noticeably different from its predecessors.
The title suggests that moviegoers will
be returning to the very start of the
noise-sensitive alien invasion, a backdrop
briefly explored in the prologue to "A Quiet
Place: Part II." Exploring how humans react to
their suddenly changing world could certainly
provide a fresh spin for the franchise,
especially since Sarnoski proved to be
extremely gifted at exploring humanity's
ability to grapple with loss in "Pig."
Ethan Hunt, the protagonist of the expansive
"Mission: Impossible" series, has had to pull
off some incredible feats throughout this
franchise. However, soon Tom Cruise's iconic
character will have to complete an especially
daunting task: nailing a two-part blockbuster.
The next installment in the "Mission:
Impossible" franchise, "Dead Reckoning,"
is going to be split across a pair of motion
pictures, the second of which will arrive in
June 2024. As titles like "Divergent:
Allegiant" have proved in the past,
taking one story and splitting it across two
movies can go very wrong very fast. However,
if Hunt could climb the world's tallest building
and survive, then it stands to reason he might
manage to make "Dead Reckoning" a
satisfying multi-film experience.
"How am I supposed to do this?" Glove smacks.
One promising aspect of the second part
of "Dead Reckoning" is that it will
feature some cast members that won't
be around for the first installment,
including Nick Offerman and Holt McCallany.
The presence of new faces indicates that
the second part of "Dead Reckoning" might
just offer something unique, rather than
act as a rehash of the first part. That's
just one of the countless reasons moviegoers
are on the edge of their seats waiting for
"Mission Impossible – Dead Reckoning
– Part Two" to show up in theaters.
After dominating the Academy Awards, Bong Joon
Ho returns to both science-fiction cinema and
English-language storytelling with his 2024
directorial effort, "Mickey 17." Based on the
book "Mickey7" by Edward Ashton, "Mickey
17" stars the endlessly versatile Robert
Pattinson as a man tasked with working on an
expedition to colonize a far-off ice planet.
From there, if prior Joon Ho movies are any
indication, the film is likely to take some
unpredictable turns and project potent
social commentary on the world around
us. There are still so few details on what this
adaptation will look and feel like, but Joon Ho's
incredible body of work makes it difficult not
to get tantalized by this project immediately.
If the film's elevator pitch
wasn't enough to excite you,
the rest of the cast just might. Aside from
Robert Pattinson taking on the lead role,
Toni Collette, Steven Yeun, Naomi Ackie, and
Mark Ruffalo are all listed as supporting cast.
Pattinson has always shown a penchant for working
with beloved auteurs like David Cronenberg, Robert
Eggers and Claire Denis, so it's incredibly
exciting to imagine what he'll accomplish as a
performer working under the filmmaker responsible
for "Parasite." Needless to say, there are more
than a few reasons to be pumped for the release of
this legendary director's next cinematic effort.
"Furiosa" is a new George Miller movie.
That fact alone should send it rocketing
toward the very top of any list of the
most anticipated movies of 2024. The
fact that it's a George Miller directorial
effort set in the "Mad Max" world, however,
makes the prospect of this cinematic
experience even more appetizing.
This time around, the character of Furiosa from
"Mad Max: Fury Road" will not be portrayed by
Charlize Theron, but by Anya Taylor-Joy. This
leading lady has been on a hot streak with
her work in movies and TV, including notable 2022
titles like "The Northman" and "The Menu." So, the
idea of her getting to work under the direction
of George Miller sounds downright extraordinary.
"Care for a demonstration?"
English actor Thom Burke will also
appear in the film's cast. While Burke may not be
a household name yet, he delivered extraordinary
work in Joanna Hogg's "The Souvenir." With a
background largely in British indies and TV,
it will be extremely revelatory to see what he
can do with a much larger canvas at his disposal
Beyond the cast, which also includes Chris
Hemsworth, "Furiosa" is bound to be home to
a practically realized spectacle that only Miller
would have the gall and imagination to pull off.
If he manages to capture even a fraction of the
"Fury Road" magic, then "Furiosa" will be only
the latest example of why any new George Miller
movie should be met with great anticipation.
The "Planet of the Apes" franchise has
seen seemingly constant updates over the
course of the last few decades, which might
make viewers think that this saga would be
running on fumes creatively. However, the most
recent trilogy of features from this universe,
two of which were helmed by "The
Batman" director Matt Reeves,
were some of the most exciting
and daring entries to date.
That's not to say "Planet of the Apes" is
incapable of churning out a dud movie — Tim
Burton's 2001 film "Planet of the Apes" was
certainly a lacking contribution to the franchie.
However, there's clearly a lot of creative
longevity within this universe, which makes the
prospect of the 2024 installment "Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes" sound especially appetizing.
According to Deadline, "Kingdom of the Planet
of the Apes" will take place decades after the
events of "War for the Planet of the Apes," though
any further plot details are wrapped up in secrecy
for now. However, the idea of a continuation
of the story first established in "Rise of
the Planet of the Apes" is certainly compelling.
Additionally, with Wes Ball as the new director,
there's plenty of possibility for some fresh new
visuals to be incorporated into this installment.
What's more, Owen Teague is tapped to play the
main ape, and his remarkable work in features
like "To Leslie" makes us enthusiastic to see what
he'll do in a motion-capture role. To summarize,
there are plenty of reasons to go bananas
for "Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes."
After finally taking on the mantle of Captain
America in the final episode of "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier," Sam Wilson will get to
headline his own feature film in "Captain America:
New World Order." Directed by "Luce" filmmaker
Julius Onah, "Captain America: New World Order"
promises to continue some of the most intriguing
elements of "The Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
However, "New World Order" is also
primed to connect Wilson's Captain
America to broader parts of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe mythology, like the
long-awaited return of Tim Blake Nelson's
Samuel Stern from "The Incredible Hulk."
This Marvel Studios feature is also positioned
to include the debut appearance of Harrison Ford
as General Thaddeus "Thunderbolt" Ross. Just the
presence of such a legendary acting giant should
put "New World Order" on many a viewer's radar.
However, the fact that it will also function as
an opportunity to see the new Captain America
soar as a big-screen leading man is without a
doubt the primary cause of the buzz that
has already begun surrounding this film.
The Dragon Warrior is back. In March 2024, Po
will return for another adventure in "Kung Fu
Panda 4." That's all that anybody in the general
public knows about this forthcoming sequel,
with even key details like the creative team
behind this follow-up shrouded in mystery.
However, ambiguity certainly won't keep
people from getting excited about all
the possibilities of seeing Po go on another
epic quest. After all, the first three "Kung
Fu Panda" movies are among the strongest
titles in the DreamWorks Animation canon,
with "Kung Fu Panda 2" standing out as a sequel
that took the franchise in a new tonal direction
without losing the core ingredients that
made the original installation so loveable.
"You gotta let go of that stuff from
the past, cause it just doesn't matter."
If the "Kung Fu Panda" franchise could pull
off a sequel as good as "Kung Fu Panda 2,"
then there's a good chance "Kung Fu Panda
4" could also be something special. Plus,
recent DreamWorks Animation titles
like "The Bad Guys" and "Puss in Boots:
The Last Wish" have been remarkably strong
in overall quality. If that hot streak of
creativity extends to this forthcoming
"Kung Fu Panda" feature, then audiences
should prepare themselves for another totally
awesome addition to the "Kung Fu Panda" saga.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe has
often concerned itself with totally
unknown superheroes who've never been
considered for the big screen before,
like the Guardians of the Galaxy or the
Eternals. However, one of its upcoming
2024 titles will be anchored by a superhero who
has not only appeared in a feature film before,
but actually led a trilogy of movies
across the late 1990s and early 2000s.
A new incarnation of Blade, once played
by Wesley Snipes, is headed to the MCU,
with this version of the character being
played by Mahershala Ali. According to The
Hollywood Reporter, the two-time Oscar
winner has such a deep passion for the
character that he outright asked Marvel
Studios to let him play the vampire hunter.
While Ali's commitment to "Blade"
has never wavered in the years
since he signed onto the role, the movie
itself has experienced several hardships
on its way to the screen, including the
loss of original director Bassam Tariq.
While those setbacks have been discouraging,
the choice of Yann Demange as the new director
of the film inspires a lot of confidence
that this feature could still turn out to
be something special. Additionally, Marvel
Studios has successfully delivered several
classics in spite of turbulent productions
in the past, so there are still a few good
reasons to remain hopeful that Ali's stint
as Blade will turn out to be a success.
"The Fall Guy" originated as a TV show starring
Lee Majors that aired on ABC for five seasons
in the 1980s. In March 2024, though, it'll be
released as an action movie headlined by Ryan
Gosling and helmed by "Bullet Train" director
David Leitch. However, Gosling isn't the only
recognizable name in this action feature:
Emily Blunt, Stephanie Hsu, Winston Duke,
Aaron Taylor-Johnson, and Hannah Waddingham
are all set to round out the ensemble cast.
"The Fall Guy" is so far out from release that
many aspects of the production are still unknown,
including just how much or how
little this motion picture will
adhere to its source material. However,
any opportunity to watch Ryan Gosling
punch people sounds like a good time at the
movies, and the supporting cast sounds ace.
Leitch's filmmaking career has had its ups
and downs, but the best of his works have
had a propulsive energy and zippy atmosphere
that's difficult to resist. Plus, his peak
effort as an auteur, 2017's "Atomic Blonde,"
also featured incredible fight choreography,
which could indicate "The Fall Guy" will feature
cool combat sequences at the very least. All in
all, the ingredients are there for this movie to
be much more than a rehash of a 1980s TV staple.
The original "Joker" may not
have been everybody's cup of tea,
but it undeniably separated itself from
the typical comic book movie adaptation
genre and remained a topic of cultural
discussion for years after its release.
After years of speculation over whether or not a
sequel to "Joker" would ever hit movie theaters,
its follow-up is officially scheduled to come
out in October 2024. Another key figure from
the the villain's comic book lore, Harley
Quinn, will also play a role in the film,
with Lady Gaga portraying her. On top
of that, this follow-up, entitled Joker:
Folie à Deux [foh-LEE AH DOO] will also be a
musical, which will allow the movie to indulge
Gaga's talents as a singer and differentiate
itself immensely from its predecessor.
While the concept of making a "Joker" sequel
may sound predictable, it's safe to assume
few fans of the original were expecting
a musical to follow it. Additionally,
the idea of Lady Gaga playing a version of
Harley Quinn with even a fraction of the
energy and passion the performer brought to
her "House of Gucci" performance sounds even
more exciting. "Joker: Folie à Deux" is bound
to be as divisive as its predecessor, but it
also sounds like the kind of sequel that swings
for the fences rather than sits on its laurels.
"Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!"
After "Titanic," audiences had to wait 12
years for a new James Cameron movie. After
"Avatar," moviegoers had to wait another 13
years to experience a fresh vision from the
filmmaker. A significantly shorter wait will exist
between "Avatar: The Way of Water" and Cameron's
next directorial effort, the untitled third
"Avatar" movie set for a December 2024 release.
While Cameron is keeping many details
of "Avatar 3" close to the vest,
Collider reports that this film will
introduce some new characters poised
to make waves throughout the entire swath of
"Avatar" sequels. David Thewlis is slated to
play a Na'vi character that will debut in this
film, while characters played by Michelle Yeoh
and Oona Chaplin will also premiere
in this installment of the franchise.
Cameron's penchant for extravagant spectacle
in the first two "Avatar" movies should make
it clear that this upcoming sequel will
continue working to that effect. It's
also exciting to know that "Avatar 3" will
introduce new characters instead of just
leaning on familiar figures from the franchise's
past. There's still so much to see on Pandora,
and that makes the idea of returning to the
planet in "Avatar 3" an immensely rousing
concept, especially since it will arrive much
sooner than the previous films in the series.
"Outstanding."